welcome to the video on basic
subtraction
let's do a little bit of review of
basic addition first
if i said
plus 3 what did this mean four plus
three
what did that equal
well there were a couple of ways we
could have viewed this we could have
said i had four of something let's say i
had four circles or
i don't know i had four lemons for for
breakfast so
one
two
three
four lemons for breakfast and let's say
i had another three lemons for lunch
one
two
three and so you could view four plus
three as how many total lemons did i
have i'm adding three to four so how
many total did i have what's one two
three four five six seven so i had a
total of seven lemons
another way we could have viewed that is
we could have drawn our number line
and i'll draw it in yellow because we're
that's not wide enough
i'll draw it in yellow because we're
talking about lemons
so let's say that's our number line
and if i start at the number let me draw
all of the numbers
two
three
four
five
six
seven so you could view you could think
about this as saying well we're on the
number line we start at the number four
right that's this number four and we're
adding 3 to it so we'll increase along
the number line by 3. so we'll go
3 and you end up at 7. so you could say
if i have 4 and i get 3 more i get 7 or
if i increase 4 by 3 i also get 7.
so what's subtraction now now because
that's what this video is about i
shouldn't waste all of our time talking
about addition so let's take the example
of 4 minus 3 what is that equal to
let me switch colors just to keep things
interesting so what is 4
minus 3
equal to
subtraction or minus is the opposite of
addition
so in addition
you're doing something more you're
adding i don't want to use the word
adding to define addition but that's
what you're doing i had four lemons and
then i had three more
in subtraction you're taking away so
this example if i started with four
lemons
let's say i had four lemons on a plate
if i'm subtracting three if i'm saying
minus three
instead of adding these three here and
getting seven i'm going to take three
away
so maybe i'm eating them or maybe i'm
giving them to you for in exchange for
watching these videos
so to take away three from this four
let's say this one goes away this one
goes away and this one goes away how
many lemons would we have left
well this is the only one that i haven't
crossed out so we would have one lemon
left
one lemon left and this would be the
lemon that's left didn't have to be that
we're not going to cross out any of the
three
another way to view that let's draw the
same
lemon colored
number line
say that this is the number line right
here
and i'll draw all the same numbers so
that's
six
seven of course the number line keeps
going
there's no largest number you can
imagine any any number that you can
think of i can think of one higher than
that so there is no largest number so
that's why we draw that arrow there yeah
i could never draw the entire number
line but anyway back to subtraction
so we're starting at four lemons right
when we added three plus three we went
to the right four spaces on the number
line and that's because the right is
increasing value so we went from four to
five that was one more five to six was
two more and seven was three more
now we're taking away from four
so what do we do what would you think we
do
well since we're taking away we're going
to decrease
the total number of lemons we have right
so we take away 1 we get to 3 take away
2 get to 2 take away 3 we took away 3
right
so we'll go back 1 2 3 along the number
line and we'll end up
at one and that's this one right here
so
just to review addition is you're doing
more of something subtraction is you are
taking away
if you think about it on the number line
addition is increasing along the number
line by that amount so in this case we
increased along the number line by three
and so we went from four to seven
in the subtraction case we decrease
back on the number line so we decrease
by the amount that you're subtracting so
in this case we decreased by
three
so we went back one two three and we had
one and the other way to do it if i have
four something if i give three away or
if i ate three of them or if i i don't
know what i did to three of them if i
lost three of them i would have one left
now let me show you some interesting
things about
subtraction so we know that four minus
three is equal to one
let me show you something else that's
interesting
what is 4
minus 1
well we could we could do we could use
either example let's do the lemon
example if i had let's do apples now i'm
bored of the lemons
let's add
one
one two
three
four i have a new pen sometimes it
doesn't draw right let's say i had four
apples right this is the example we're
dealing with and i were to eat one of
them so one of them were to go away how
many apples would i have left well three
one two three
so four minus one is equal to three
and if we did it on the number line if
we started at four
and we subtracted one we took one away
so we're going to become one smaller
we go back one we get three
either way works but isn't this
interesting four minus three is equal to
one and four minus one is equal to three
now that that you might say well is this
you know did i pick the numbers just so
it worked well it turns out that it's
always true
for if some well i don't wanna get too
technical but this we're already
touching on on something that you'll
learn later on maybe in algebra one day
but actually i don't want to go into
that right now
so where does this come from well this
is also
based on the fact that three plus one i
didn't want to confuse you so i
apologize if i did
but i'll show you another interesting
thing
what is three plus one
three plus one is equal to what well
that's easy you know that from basic
addition you could start on the number
line at
three
and add one to it and where do you end
up
you end up at four three plus one is
equal to four or you could have started
at one on the number line and added
three
one two three and you would have also
ended up at four right so
we also know that you could have
switched this either way
both of those are equal to four
what do you see here well there's
there's a bunch of things i've written
here and they all kind of relate to each
other one plus three is equal to four
three plus one is equal to four
four minus one is three
essentially four minus one and getting
three is the exact same
you're saying the same thing as three
plus one is equal to 4
right this statement says if i add 1 to
3 i get 4.
this is saying if i take away 1 from 4 i
get 3.
so if i start at 4 and move back i get
3. this is saying if i start at three
and i move up one i get four
hopefully that gives you a little bit of
intuition about what subtraction is in
the next video i'll just do as many
basic subtraction problems i can do in
ten minutes and and then you'll be ready
to do the exercises see you soon